did you grow up with asians
no
no not until you guys came to our
community oh we came to your community
yeah the beauty supply store
were you ever grocery store were we ever
friends with asians growing up they
didn't go to my school no oh when's the
first time you became a friend with an
asian
you you
49 years later yeah
i'm trying to think
[Laughter]
i'm not lord i'm not being racist but i
really don't know no
okay so let me just be honest then can i
be honest yeah
i grew up with in the suburbs of san
diego there was no black people how many
did you have in your school
one and a half i don't even know wow
the white dude was really tan i don't
know maybe you know he was black but
there are some suburbs in san diego that
are super white so white so it's like
the only real like black friends i got
was from comedy yeah and then you just
show up at a club and then like you know
you see and the first guy i met was this
kid named kareem
right and he was tall he had a big fro
and he just came up to me and goes
what's up man and then he gave me he
gave me a hug and i'm like i couldn't
believe it i was like it's just like in
the movies
then he spit on me
yeah right no no you know and i try to
do the like i try to be like you know he
gave me a hug and when we departed i was
just like
like you know i did a thing with my body
oh wow and i couldn't believe it was
like i'm i'm in training day or
something yeah yeah yeah yeah
god damn it
and then you and then you know um i came
to l.a and then
martin lawrence's um road manager goes
hey
martin wants you to um
every time he plays the store he just
wants you to open
right so then it's like
i'm like in the green room with martin
lawrence and all these guys and i'm
meeting everybody
and it was just like um
it was just a magical [ __ ] time but
also i didn't grow up with blind people
so i'm just kind of learning
culturally what do you look at me like
that for
no i believe i don't know why but you're
looking at me like i'm going to say
something like i'm going to cancel
myself no i'm not going to let you
cancel yourself
i mean i understand i mean i remember
when the asians chinese people first
started to come for hearing of them
which they took over the nail shop those
are asians right yeah
cause you know you i you know
i just i don't i don't [ __ ] want to
say the wrong thing but when they
started to take over the nail shops in
my community and they just started
popping up everywhere and then
we became popular and all the beauty
supply stores came so they started
coming to the community because at first
they were coming into our community
easing out through the look of stones
we have more liquor stoves and churches
than any [ __ ] thing yeah so
you know now they flood our community
because for some reason white america we
don't realize we spend the most money in
this [ __ ] country black people do
yeah yeah so you know that was my first
interaction when they started to come in
our community yeah
um you grew up in atlanta yeah i grew up
in georgia it was just you did it
well alfredo oh bush
tell me tell me about that i moved there
white black farms and then this guy
that was it
yeah but that's where all the money is
now it is no all the money is bro you
grew up like i grew up
no but the way you described i didn't
have a country club
[ __ ] you probably had a crunch you just
didn't belong to the country club yeah
but you did was there golfing there was
golfing well there you go [ __ ] why did
you why would you belong to your parents
on on beauty supply stores he's a tennis
player his cousin owns a beauty supply
store oh my my yeah my my my parents own
these clothing stores did they own a wig
shop too we owned a wig shop we yeah
we're in that game as well but then it's
like
we're in the wig game bro and
we're good what's up doc but um then uh
but then but i grew up my parents my
parents were doing well in life yeah so
we grew up in like with a swimming pool
you know i mean white picket fans
affluence very affluent right yeah very
i see yeah but then here's the thing
though what do your parents think about
you ain't butt ass naked acting like you
po you got a script to make [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] this peppa but what are you is
that your life miss pat just listen
i'm surprised ain't that chicken feet
my dad used to beat the [ __ ] up with the
golf club i heard that [ __ ] i heard
you tell that story yeah oh you i don't
know where i seen he said i came across
a story about your daddy beating you you
had me [ __ ] hollering yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah my mom she knocked my mom's teeth
out he was a raging alcoholic so yeah we
had affluence right i was molested not
by my dad but
someone in the neighborhood so that you
know you have your trauma and [ __ ] yeah
everybody got trauma everyone's got no i
know some dudes though i know some
comics
they have nothing
they're not funny that's true they're
not nobody stuck no thumb up your ass
yeah nothing that's that's the that's
true that's [ __ ] that's the last if you
if you look at a comic and they say oh
my mother does my laundry i'd be like
can you please go rob a bank
get the [ __ ] off
nobody gives a [ __ ] about your mama
doing your line you you [ __ ] yeah yeah
[Laughter]
my mama does his laundry yeah your mom
is my lady but it is asian mothering is
a different oh yeah they're very clingy
and
uh cookie and cook for you yeah like
even when you don't want it like today i
didn't want her to she's just roaming
around like vacuuming when i don't do
anything i'm like mom sit down have a
meal with us she can't do it she has to
be doing something and it's always got
to be in the cleaning department can can
you send her a while i will oh my god
it's like her favorite sport in life is
cleaning even though people like that
yeah it like brings her comfort or
something or even well don't [ __ ] with
her comfort
don't [ __ ] with her comfort loan your
mother
loan your mama out
we want her to be real comfortable
can you can you who
fly her to indianapolis keep your mama
comfortable like a [ __ ]
did you move to indianapolis i live in
indianapolis yeah oh you like it there
[ __ ] no
why why are you there then my husband
works at general motors
and so that's what originally got me
there i'm getting ready to move back to
atlanta back to atlanta yeah yeah la was
never your thing i know i can't do this
oh oh carrie eatness place
[Laughter]
fake titties and i can't do all of this
[ __ ] you